It is difficult to balance time between work and life.
In today's fast - changing world, everybody works hard and is as busy as a bee.
Many people cannot enjoy a completely rewarding personal life.
Focusing too much on work results in a life out of balance and eventually in stress.
One thing that stresses out a lot of people is the task of cleaning.
It seems unjust that in this modern world, it takes just as long for you to clean your house...
...as it took your grandmother's grandmother to clean hers.
If you're overwhelmed by cleaning, you need to rethink your cleaning priorities.
Even if you don't make the bed for one day or don't do the dishes after a meal,...
...that doesn't affect the quality of your life.
Only do what absolutely needs to be done and let the other things go.
Plan your cleaning schedule to fit your work schedule.
Leave big tasks for your day off.
Nobody expects you to be a superman or a superwoman.
Remember, balance doesn't mean doing everything.
And maintaining balance is better than running ragged.